en cette soirée du 31 décembre où chacun
de nous s'apprête à fêter joyeusement le
nouvel an ma première pensée va à tous
ceux qui ne pourront pas participer à la
joie générale à ce que frappe le malaise
un deuil la maladie l'extrême vieillesse
ou simplement la pauvreté ne les
oublions pas et que chacun nous s'il le
peut fasse quelque chose pour les aider
à eux avoue j'ai dit ce soir avec tout
mon coeur d'homme et de français bonne
année que 1970 vous apporte ce que vous
souhaitez
santé bonheur familial succès dans vos
études ou dans votre travail et pour
notre peuple pour tous les peuples
ce bien suprême qu'est la paix comme une
laque 170 soit aussi l'année du
renouveau qu'après les épreuves subies
les périls une fois encore surmonter
notre pays
puis se reprendre dans le calme
son effort vers le progrès vers le
bien-être vers la justice
il y faut de la patience mais l'avenir
appartient au peuple patient
je disais dans le calme j'ajoute dans
l'amitié
puissent tous les français se sentir les
uns des autres solidaire enfants de la
même patrie unis pour le meilleur comme
ils ont su l'être dans le pire
notre vieux pays riches de jeunesse et
d'espoir il dépend de nous que son
avenir soit un avenir de prospérité et
de grandeur il y à 25 ans exactement
je m'en souviens dans l'hiver glacées de
la libération
j'accompagnais le général de gaulle qui
rendait visite sous la neige aux villes
de la banlieue parisienne par tous notre
peuple mal nourris mal chauffés mal
vêtues s'acharnait à travailler pour
refaire la france que notre jeunesse y
songe et que c'est m le lui en sais rien
ne se gagne que dans l'effort il ya un
nouveau d'être gagnée que dans la
fraternité
françaises français
ayons confiance que l'on nouveau soit
celui de l'espérance bonne année